I was accused last
weekend, I, I don't know,
this is up to the listener to decide;
but I was accused by my
compatriots, the chilled chums,
of not being very chill and, and,
and being sort of ratcheted
up and coming in hot.
And that may be the case. I don't know.
I'm, I'm humble enough
to accept that I am,
despite incredible powers (Matt chuckles)
I am-
[Sona] Oh my God.
A human and flawed.
And so it's possible that
I was not chill last week,
and if that's the case, I'm sorry
and I will to try to be more chill.
[Sona] Hmm.
During this episode,
I'll do the best I can.
So, with that in mind, let's, let's begin.
Sona, it's nice to have you on the show.
It's very nice to be here.
But you don't, yeah. Okay. You seem okay.
(All laugh)
I don't wanna, we were just talking
about murder in the summer.
And so I realized that's not a
very chill topic to bring up.
So, I have nothing to say right now.
[Conan] Well, let me explain.
Because all I have in
my mind is murder. Okay.
Before we came on the air. On the air,
before we pressed record,
whatever is the correct term,
Matt, what's the correct term?
I think press record. But you know-
[Sona] Started recording
it's a general term.
I think people would forgive you for that.
Okay. I don't understand
the podcast format.
I actually still don't
understand television
after doing it for 27
years. So you'll forgive me
if I, if I'm a little
clumsy in my wording,
but the point we were, before
we started this episode,
we were all just chatting;
and of course, I would say
the one thing the three of
us really have in common
is, maybe a lot of people have this,
but we all are very obsessed with murder.
(Sona agrees)
I love, and, I don't love murder,
I mean, that's a terrible thing to say.
Yes, in a perfect world,
I would be able to murder.
What? What? (Matt laughs)
But I understand that there
are social conventions
and laws, and I, I don't
want to go to prison
so I will not murder.
What a-
[Conan] Despite my -
What a sick thing to say. Okay.
Despite my insatiable desire for murder
(Sona laughs loudly)
and the constant voice in my head
that says, "Murder, murder,
you know it's what you want,
you know it's what you're good at."
(Sona laughs)
[Matt] Sometimes that's not
just in your head by the way,
that you say that out loud.
(Sona continues laughing)
By the way, I'm saying this,
I think in a very chill way.
You did come in fairly chill this episode,
I want to say, you didn't come in hot.
[Conan] And you know what?
My tone is still very chill.
(Sona laughs)
As I tell you, (Matt laughs) my greatest,
my greatest desire in life
is to, to wantonly murder,
rob other people of their
lives and get away with it.
[Sona] Oh my God! (laughing)
But there you go. That's,
and I'm just saying that
as a chill chum.
Yeah.
[Sona] Before you even said
that, if you did murder
and someone came up to me and said,
"Hey, did you ever think
he'd be the kind of guy
who'd murder?" I'd be
like, "Yes, absolutely".
Yeah
[Sona] He talks about murder all the time.
I'm obsessed with murder.
[Sona] Yeah!
And what is interesting
is that, Sona, you know,
I hired Sona. We all do
things we later regret,
but I did hire Sona
(Conan and Matt laugh).
[Sona] That's unnecessary.
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
Unnecessary, terrible.
Unnecessary. Terrible.
I love you Sona, but I did
hire you, and one of the things
we did early on because I'd
just moved out to Los Angeles,
this is like 11 years ago,
we'd just moved out to Los Angeles,
Sona and I were, I think we were somewhere
in the car together cause
we had to do something.
And you said, "Oh wait, this
is near the, the, you know,
the scene of the first Manson murders."
You know, the, on Cielo Drive.
Well, we were on Benedict
Canyon, which is -
Benedict Canyon. And then the two of us
were immediately like,
"Oh, we've got to go up there and see it",
which I know sounds ghastly
and, and, and everything.
But we were both, we both
knew every single detail
of, you know, Manson and
the whole history of Manson.
And that's when we realized,
okay this is something
we have in common. We have
many things that we're,
that we aren't in common,
where we were not alike.
I could go on at length about those.
[Sona] Nope. Move on. Okay. Yeah.
I cherish America.
Oh, wow!
[Matt] Geez.
Okay
I, whatever. But-
You were telling a nice
story about us looking
at the house where, you know-
Yeah, what a nice story!
[Sona] What a nice story
about driving. (Matt laughs)
What a nice tale! Of us
retracing, retracing the steps.
But we knew all the people
in the car, we knew then,
you know, about what
they did the next night.
We knew, we knew everything;
and then I realized
that whenever I'm traveling
or going anywhere,
the first thing I try and
look for is the forensic files
because they show one after
another, after another,
after another; and I just watch those.
[Sona] Uh huh.
And I'm fascinated with that stuff.
And Matt, you have some
interest in murder?
Yeah, I suppose I grew up in the place
where the night stalker did his
nights stalking in Whittier.
And so it was really kind
of big in the community
obviously at the time.
Right. That was a big story-
[Matt] Yeah.
That was a big thing. Yeah.
And my wife was in a play with a guy
who did a double murder
and dismembered the bodies
and spread them throughout a park.
Oh, my God!
[Conan] Wait, what?
[Sona] This is not chill.